can you recall a time that in your
career you were sure that you had quote
made it and then as things happen in
this town
you never really make it until you've
actually received the check or you show
up or whatever there's so many variables
and then another time when you thought
I'd never work again in this business
and you were you were pleasantly
surprised well there are times I thought
I'd never make in this business I
remember being in New York City as a
young actor you know and I graduated
from NYU School of the Arts tonight got
a part in the Anibal Samba company and
that's pretty prestigious and worked a
couple more gigs as an accurate stage
actor and then couldn't pay my rent
didn't work for it six six or eight
months unemployment ran out and I ended
up panhandling on the street and bill
before that me my girlfriend says till
you put on these trench coats even in
the summertime and we saw these big
pockets on the inside we'd go to the ANP
supermarket we put meat and stuff in a
minute
we drive like maybe some cereal and just
that was a low low low point did I pan
handled and it was like I was a drug
head you know then I found transyl
meditation
other things and I'd saved my wife
another times would be when a powers
town USA was a hit show on I think CBS
Alex Haley Norman Lear couple seasons
making great money high lifestyle I said
okay now I then this I proved myself as
an actor didn't work for two years it's
like made me really question my talent
quit acting went to the American Film
Institute ranked at Film Institute made
a film the Aaron short and called the
hero awards and stuff nobody would bite
nobody would take me as an actor as a
director got depressed went away to a
meditation retreat David Jake my agent
calls me and says come in - right away -
because David jegos wants to see you
possibly his chute Knott's landing
I was there I went pack job so fast got
back on Monday I was in David check ups
office he and I talked I said thank you
and got home got a call my agent you're
hired nicely and I called everybody I
know a man is just like heaven heaven in
heaven Joe Wallenstein a producer on my
last day of prep call you know uh since
office has offices at Bill great prep
you know you would make it man because
you're great but you could tell by your
real I said what realism well the real
let you send us from your other shows I
said I just got out of a if I may I'd
Scout my this is wait a minute goes in
David Jacobs office David Jacobs had mix
my box up with somebody else's so I got
hired by mistake so they followed me
around for the first three days was they
know what I was doing
that was one of the higher points of my
career because it was like I I mean I
got multiple episodes of that show and
Mobile's holds up other shows and based
upon that particular triumph from me and
that was that was at low and then I came
to a high then I directed like you know
Sister Act two and other films and
hoodlum and movies but you know it's
like you think okay I've proven myself
here but if it doesn't make the exerting
amount of money no matter if they meant
if it breaks even there's a certain
profit okay
but for most of us that are black
directors in this industry if it doesn't
just blow the roof off it's not easy
you